heitinga por experimentos económicos
el canadiense de vícar y los
estadounidenses joe inglés líquido inves
fueron premiados con el nobel de
economía el swedish academy of sciences
estudia de sider la real academia sueca
de la ciencia ha decidido hoy a entregar
el premio berries riksbank en ciencias
económicas en memoria de alfred nobel
con una mitad para david karp por sus
contribuciones empíricas a la economía
laboral leiber economics
y la otra mitad de manera conjunta a
george jahn gris y guido inventa por sus
contribuciones metodológicas al análisis
de las relaciones casuales sud y
análisis
los nuevos noveles usaron experimentos
que se basan en situaciones de la vida
real para revolucionar la investigación
empírica ingresé y ben se especializaron
en el desarrollo de esta metodología
carla aplicó a la economía laboral uno
de los ejemplos citados fue un análisis
de la influencia cubana en el mercado
laboral de miami en los años 80 cuando
fidel castro permitió a los cubanos
salir de la isla el reconocimiento
mundial viene con un millón de dólares
que deberán repartirse
y
descubrimos que lo que pensábamos que
estaba bien está mal pensábamos que los
salarios mínimos dañaría mucho el empleo
y resulta que cuando miras los datos de
la manera correcta encuentras que los
salarios mínimos del tamaño que han sido
aplicados en los estados unidos o en
alemania por ejemplo no son
particularmente dañinos para el empleo
en particular lejos
pamplona el sueco alfred nobel inventor
de la dinamita dejó parte de su fortuna
para la creación de estos premios
anuales de física química medicina paz y
literatura el sector galardón la
economía fue añadido por el banco
central de suecia en 1968